[Music]
change through trade for years that was
Germany's China policy
former Chancellor Angela Merkel
championed the idea throughout her 16
years in power suggesting that making
money and fostering change go hand in
hand but was it a sham it seems to me
changed through trade was a very nice
narrative that allowed Germany to focus
exclusively on its Economic and Business
interests
while claiming that it was doing so in
order to
pursue a more
reform-oriented approach in China for
the
photography is China has been
engines are growing but this has made
Germany dangerously dependent but if you
look at a couple of the kind of key
clusters of dependency
um we're now particularly down to parts
of the car
um the auto sector and the chemical
sector and I think that's where you have
the real dependencies and this can have
serious implications
economic relations can be weaponized
interdependence can be used and this
kind of dependencies that exists can be
leveraged for political interests and
indeed we see that countries are willing
to do so China under the all-powerful Xi
Jinping has undergone profound change
the economy has reached new heights but
instead of opening up politically she
has doubled down on authoritarianism
Beijing has suppressed freedoms in Hong
Kong and it stands accused of
persecuting the we were a minority in
xinjiang
to top it off experts say there is a
very real danger that China might invade
Taiwan in the coming years
China has internally become more
authoritarian more repressive and also
externally more aggressive more
offensive when it comes to promoting its
own interests and after securing a third
term in October 2022 there is no sign of
Xi Jinping going anywhere
now he is taking a tighter grip of
China's economy the idea of change
through trade looks Dead with big
implications for foreign companies in
China we're seeing more of an impetus to
squeeze foreign firms out of the markets
even of sectors of the Chinese German
firms had had done very well in before
so I think the writing is on the wall
that yes there may be a few more years
of profit to be made in some of these
areas
um but the in in the medium term not
even the long term and we're already
facing a situation in which there will
be
um a squeeze on those firms capacity to
to do good business there
so the writing is on the wall yet the
new government has been wrestling with
what to do about it
the Coalition deal it signed last year
looked tough with passages on Taiwan and
human rights
that's the Hallmark of the green party
which holds important Ministries in the
government
is
but the man at the top doesn't seem so
sure Chancellor Olaf Schultz has pushed
through a controversial deal allowing a
Chinese State Enterprise to buy a stake
in Germany's most important port Hamburg
the decision was met with uproar from
his own Coalition Partners most notably
from the greens
green foreign minister annalina bearbok
insists Germany's strategy towards China
must change the science is
foreign
[Music]
's decision to travel to China with a
business delegation is only adding to
the divisions
this could have been a stripped-down
political visit designed to send a few
critical messages to Xi Jinping and
wrapped up
um uh quickly and efficiently without
this part of the agenda coming into it
again instead this is all the kind of
dependent companies coming in doubling
down on some of their Investments which
we've seen in the last period of time
and then seeming to do so with full
political support
so where does that leave Germany's China
strategy
Germany will not just have to look at
how to diversify economic relations but
actually how to reduce strategic
dependencies on China particularly in
critical areas such as raw materials and
for example areas such as wind turbines
solar modules and electric batteries for
electric vehicles crucial decisions lie
ahead but it's not clear if the German
government can make up its mind